[Música]
o que é invisível aos olhos e só se ver
com o coração de pai
após dez anos de tentativas de um filho
biológico adotamos duas crianças uma de
quatro anos o batatinha e outra de sete
anos o preto nossos amados filhos hoje a
primeira coisa que a gente fez foi dar
uma bicicleta para cada um mas me
incomodava muito porque passou um tempo
e o batatinha não conseguia andar na
bicicleta direito e ele corria atrás das
crianças que estavam de bicicleta
cheguei para ele e esse filho vamos lá
tentar andar de bicicleta eu vou te
ensinar ele disse sim pai vamo eu fui lá
naquela rua botei a bicicletinha do lado
que botei ele sentado segurei no
banquinho e comecei a andar com ele pra
lá e pra cá e conforme o tempo foi
passando e ele começou a conseguir se
equilibrar sozinho eu fui largando a mão
e eu disse tirando a minha mão do
banquinho de repente eu estava sem a mão
no banquinho e ele não via isso e
continuar andando ele num certo instante
eu comecei a bater palma do lado dele
ele olhou pra mim e em começou a tremer
eu disse vai vai devagar e ele foi
parando parou e disse que não devia ter
feito isso
como assim filho não foi legal eu disse
foi muito legal pai
e aí eu me sentei do lado com uma dor
nas costas e comecei a me esticar e
quando eu vi o batatinha estava andando
sozinho de novo
dei um pulo ali e eu pulei e fui atrás
dele e corri atrás dele cheguei do lado
dele e ele sorrisão pra mim olhando e
sorrindo e eu disse olha pra frente vai
devagarinho o filho bem devagar e isso
equilibra isso aí e ele foi indo foi em
thatta chegando no final vai freando
freando e ele freou a bicicleta e quando
ele freou
é como se fosse um corpo eu vibrei
ele olhou pra mim e eu disse tu
conseguiu ele é pai foi igual a ti não
desistir
eu me emocionei naquele instante
peguei ele fiquei a tarde inteira
andando
sabe aquele tempo que não quer que
termine nunca que passa vai passando o
tempo e tudo diz que vida maravilhosa
era amor de pai e de filho ali chegamos
no final da tarde pegamos a bicicletinha
de botamos no porta mala ele entrou no
carro e atrás ele disse pai sabe por que
eu conseguir
eu digo sei porque tô sobre de
concentrar ato foi bem tu conseguiu
muito bem se equilibrar
ele não vai tem um segredo eu como assim
filho tem um segredo
qual é o segredo e diz pai era enquanto
andava na bicicleta sem todo lado
eu imaginava que a tua mão estava
segurando no banquinho
eu fiquei ali a imaginar quantas vezes
nós olhamos para a nossa vida e tem o
papai ea mamãe segurando no nosso
banquinho para a gente se equilibrar e
pensar que anos antes eu ea minha esposa
fomos preencher a ficha de adoção e lá
dizia assim com que idade você quer
adotar o seu filho até dois anos até 5
até 15 até 17 eo meu deus não eu quero é
21 bebê de preferência com irmãos 2 até
5 5 mas não imagina eu quero só um é o
que eu quero aqui mas eu mais do que
nunca eu não sabia que a minha esposa ia
fazer um trabalho numa casa de acolhida
ela conheceu o preto e o batatinha e
ficou maravilhada chegou em casa e me
falou amor
encontrei o filho eu digo que encontrou
vamos lá buscar ele vamos correr lá
buscar eles e tal
vamo vamo lá amor vão conhecer os dois
os dois maninho seu em dois era de
informática como
deu tudo certinho um homem pensou quanto
vai custar essa história
putz mas eu fui lá fui lá eo preto veio
pra mim com aquele sete aninhos dele me
deu uma medalhinha de um outro time eu
olhei aquela medalhinha e disse que
legal
muito obrigado mas útil é de outro time
ele tomou aquela medalhinha saiu
correndo e me trouxe outra e aquelas
medalhinha era do meu time e eu fiquei
impressionado com aquilo
olhei pra ele pensei esse só pode ser
meu filho pó
o pam tatinha estava do lado dinho assim
a realidade o lado e eu cheguei perto
dele e ele começou a cantar assim você
mar me mata papai
ai ai ai ai eu fiquei impressionado
a música era sensual mas tinha a palavra
papai o jeito dele dançar
que maravilha eu fiquei encantado ele
dançando ali pra mim e começou a chegar
a outras crianças de 5 de 10 de 15 anos
e começaram a dançar junto e estava tudo
muito lindo maravilhoso mas começar a
botar o batatinha para trás eo
preocupado com batatinha lá atrás e eles
olhavam pra mim eu pensava por eles
estão me dizendo alguma coisa estão
dizendo tio eu também sirva para ser teu
filho aquilo me doeu eu sair dali disse
para minha esposa na hora
bons dois lá pra casa se vocês não sabem
são 50 mil crianças no brasil essa fila
não pára de crescer em abrigos cinco mil
delas atualmente estão aptas à adoção
do outro lado temos 40 mil pretendentes
mas porque essa essa conta não fecha
entre os dois é porque esses 40 mil como
nós criamos um filho 90% delas querem um
filho até 6 anos
do outro lado as crianças que estão nos
abrigos têm mais de seis anos
assim nasceu o projeto de nosso amor
fraternal
o propósito é ajudar a inspirar acelerar
e qualificar adoções de crianças e
adolescentes sem nenhum fim lucrativo
a gente começou com livre com os amigos
nos ajudaram a fazer as historinhas que
eu tô contando aqui pra vocês são
verdadeiras são originais
a partir dele nasceram vários projetos
ea maioria desses projetos tem a parte
da tecnologia porque o trabalho com
tecnologia e eu sei uma coisa
a tecnologia está mudando o mundo e como
é que não vai conseguir botar na mão
dessa criança
desses gurizinho segure asinhas um papai
e uma mamãe tem que ajudar
isto dentre tantos que passaram
nós tivemos a idéia de um aplicativo de
adoção adoção
esse aplicativo teve mais de 40 corações
trabalhando nele 40 corações amor
a gurizada da universidade dizia que
queria mudar o mundo
não faltava uma aula estava lá o
ministério público estava o tribunal de
justiça todos juntos para uma causa
bacana abre o teu coração e deixa o amor
te surpreender é quebra de paradigma
pois ele teve repercussão nacional
a gente deu entrevista para tudo que era
lado mas não era só porque aquele que
quer ser papai e mamãe via coração é
porque a causa ela é social também
porque quando essa gurizada chega aos 18
anos no abrigo
se não teve papai e mamãe sai vai embora
te vira como sem papai mamãe outras
coisas é social sim pois é
e esse ano foi muito legal porque
aconteceu a primeira adoção pelo
aplicativo
a mamãe nos contou que ela abrir o
aplicativo e ela queria um filho até
dois anos mas ela começou a navegar e
viu de 15 de 18 de 12
o irmão sem irmãos e se apaixonou por um
casalzinho um casal de irmãos um com 11
outro com 12
ela disse eu olhei o vídeo aquele e ela
só pediam que queriam ser felizes que
queria uma família eles não queriam ir
para a disney
eles não queriam carrinho de controle
remoto eles queriam uma família
telefonou para o pai
o futuro papai marcelo e disse encontrei
nossos filhos e ele filhos plural 2
eu já vi essa história que coincidência
pois é o aplicativo até o momento já
ajudou na adoção de quatro crianças mais
de dez guardas provisórios e
aproximações e 150 manifestações de
interesse de adotar algumas crianças
nunca tinham tido nem manifestação de
interesse e aí logo no início da nossa
vida a milhares adotiva amorosa eu
estava vindo da terapia do futebol todas
as terças-feiras eu jogo futebol que é
uma terapia e vinha com os filhos os
filhos iam jogar comigo e vinham preto
na frente do carro e o batatinha trás e
de repente o preto virou pra mim e disse
pai também no final do ano pai e vamos
ganhar presente de natal eu fui disse
olha filho e ele já correu na frente é
pai eu passei de ano com notas
excelentes
eu tenho obedecido a mãe eu tenho lido
todos os livros que tu me dá
eu digo muito bem meu filho porque os
estudos ea educação é coisa mais
importante que o pai a mãe tem que te dá
que a gente dá para os filhos e
batatinha lá atrás não é não pai eu como
que não é assim
além de tudo conhecer o mundo o mundo
ser maravilhoso com outros olhos não vai
enxergar ele ainda vai ganhar um
dinheirinho
mas não é não pai não é o mais
importante
eu digo é o mais importante que os pais
têm que deixar foi enfático com ele
pois ele foi mais enfático comigo e ele
virou para mim e disse assim vai
o mais importante é o amor é o amor
ele tinha 45 anos a mãe disse que é o
amor
ae pois é estive pensando no amor o amor
familiar de todos nós
no meu caso o amor pela sua compra pela
minha companheira já 20 anos que dura
mais de 20 que maravilha é amor tudo
nasceu na paixão e hoje amor aquele amor
incondicional pelos nossos filhos amados
que a gente se joga na boca do jacaré
para salvar eles o amor fraternal que
temos por seres humanos e quais vinhos a
nós como aqueles gurizinhos lá pedindo
um papai e uma mamãe
esses dias lendo sobre o sentido da vida
e do amor
eu vi o dalai lama dizer o verdadeiro
propósito da vida é buscar a felicidade
a felicidade o que é legal feliz mas não
dá pra ser feliz toda hora não tem como
ser feliz tem que ser até meio chato eu
já ouvi falar que tu
mas tem uma coisa eu posso ter vários
momentos de felicidade se utilizar o
amor
se eu colocar amor na minhas coisas são
vários os momentos que eu vou ter
então voltando à nossa pergunta do
início aqui o que é invisível aos olhos
e só se ver com o coração de pai
pois é esse ano no dia dos pais
meu filho me trouxe esse cartão zin
dizia com a letra dele maravilhosa o
essencial é invisível aos olhos e só se
ver com o coração santos o pr
o pequeno príncipe que eu dei pra eles
lê eu fui surpreendido
fiquei emocionado com aquilo portanto
com adoção review invisível viu o
essencial de que não basta ser pai
biológico tem que adotar
não basta na vida a gente viver a vida a
gente tem que adotar vida
a adoção do yuri do wesley foi a maior
felicidade da nossa vida e eles nasceram
pra nossa família aos 47 anos de idade
além do amor e carinho eles ainda vieram
prontos para jogar futebol comigo 5 mil
crianças e adolescentes estão
cadastrados para adoção no brasil 94 por
cento têm mais de seis anos esperam por
uma família que pode não aparecer
elas podem ter uma vida nova com a gente
te f considere uma adoção tardia
essa aqui é o photo hoje da minha
família
e aquela era anterior
logo que iniciou a minha família essa é
a atual depois de sete anos de
convivência eu garanto para vocês têm
muitos momentos de amor e por isso a
gente é feliz obrigado
[Aplausos]